a lot of political comedy Trump should
we oh sure you know I feel like I've
been doing this since Nixon Nixon was
like herpes you'd think he was gonna
break lair up again at her peace makes
me herpes does that I always know I got
herpes when I hear that sound and I've
been doing that joke for years and
everybody always starts talking to me
like I got her 9 I don't have rights
it's a pipe just making a point anyway
so so I feel like I've been doing this
forever and I was sort of looking at
this like meme's in the last election I
got a do now I feel like I'm in a bad
cop movie you know where it's like will
the old lieutenants got one more shift
before he retires wait there's some
problems down at the polling station so
now that trumps here it's like you can't
you can't leave comedy now it does it
feel to you like you're needed now more
than ever yeah I just got to figure out
a way to make some money at it I think
I'm gonna bet everything I have on me
I'm gonna bet everything I have on the
if he builds the wall I'm gonna bet
everything I have on the Mexican
pole-vaulting team everything you do a
you know all the a political comedy you
do you you call yourself a pacifist
I am a pacifist and you know what people
say to you when you're past this car the
first thing uh well what would you done
about World War two I wouldn't have
started World War one right right right
out of a sequel right you know you could
have destroyed the whole franchise right
I mean when they start rolling on some
Archduke when it has anyone heard of an
Archduke an Archduke cut so I know one
Archduke in my life yeah arts to your
God not Archduke Ferdinand and I mean
you know no offense to the guy but if
you're riding around in an open touring
car with that hat on you're kind of
asking
I didn't think I'd hear an Archduke
Ferdinand oh you know there's credit
hours available exactly I was gonna say
you get extra points for that
do you get frustrated you get frustrated
with the media well yeah I mean you know
I think we all do yeah I'm watching CNN
during the insurrection in Ferguson and
they put up one of those dildo ik poles
they do dildo ik is that a I love that I
coined this that's fantastic you can use
it still do it do you think of this pole
I find it just doing the utter dildo
city Neal Gossett II yes yes so you know
thread that around until Doha sysm and I
think it's gonna come in a handy term
for the next four years
yeah but what was the poll they put up
the question was is racism getting
better in America and so I tweeted him
right back and said oh yeah it's at the
top of its game
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you